I believe dar doc has the components to
be one of the best players in North
America you're gonna see him as one of
the NA rising stars what really defines
star doc um I'm just a dumb seventeen
year old kid who played too much
soloqueue and got lucky what's up guys
my name is Colin McNeill for the score
eSports dar doc is a name that comes
with some baggage his attitude is
confident to the point of being cocky
but if you're gonna talk a big game you
better be willing to back it up on the
rift and dar doc has no trouble doing
just that so while he's killing it with
his new team in the spring split we
thought it would be the perfect time to
bring you the best of dar Talk
[Music]
just pick those hit bang is there whoa
dar doc fly straight through fangs and a
for everyone darn ik tries to fly back
to help the team monsoon to give pain
out of the fight and take the riders the
Arctic assault prediction on - licorice
board right under the turret wreckage
since Karen hooked in low on health
knock up comes through there's the old
different GP the ball comes in shock
wave does catch piglet but gameplay
strong hard kicks in another and that's
the killer
Oriana pillow before fighting GPS let me
tell you that far that gets one trade it
back in by GBM lissandra's lovo and to
the front line goes Warlow a triple kill
birds are duck killing everybody with a
Quadra kill lucky here shock I'm gonna
find sense and the rusyn to come back
through the here comes the engage and
Donna doesn't want to be part of this oh
my gosh just kidding takes went down
blocks the shot door knock is amazing
double kill comes through it's through
they're gonna trade his life for that
kill that was actually immaculate three
to one lead over to immortal beautiful
let's get to the wall and Donna she'll
be able to kill Oh sick okay there we go
he's back he's back he's back and Lisa
Lee sin or Lee sin rengar cotton coach
mist flash by flame does nothing yeah oh
it's gonna be a burned oldie gonna get
on to the junkie to get the kill on our
daughter has to choose how to use the
porosity it's gonna be for more damage
the double kill comes through once again
the score line is tar doc versus TM
since their format from hood now Donna
Karan's inste goes for it absolutely
looks for the ulti get some panties fell
only been out dog god [ __ ] faith up
Phoenix has that teleport as well we may
see that happen if this can't be a kill
pulled in mid lanes getting some support
lemon well it comes down bot Lane gets
it he'll and they also for a gank in the
mid lane for khawarij shot straight and
barrel Ching gets some damage but guess
what they still want in and Spence karat
is gone
officer town and Team Liquid I still
push again to keep flash catches on sir
he gets exercised and tau D goes into
the pokeball tio 4 kills in a row and
now if the Ericsson getting caught and
the mid lane flashes over looks like he
could be safe here reg rock is on one
more under toast gonna bring him in
right through Paulie turns it as the
where's off big play there from the ad
carry and the whole demon around just a
little bit too long no instead Kate
gonna get Justin he's dead as well
thought up you can see so happy about
that he may have just saved the game for
immortals there pretty much I wanted to
make worlds immortals didn't really care
too much about it so I wanted to join a
team that would get me there
special trying to run from Doc aphromoo
and sticks a some quick beat on him but
not quick enough to get away from the
kick of dart off see oh jeez they might
be able to make a birdie nice play on
two arrow kicks and back takes him down
I think it's stunned upped our dogs got
yet another kick and zig is gonna be
dropping everyone's a bit setting
hey char come out damage goes through
expresses gonna be going down more
health bars evaporated and three died
for Phoenix one a double kill for dart
off the wet the wet noodle beginning we
can't funnel here with they're both on
topic added what a shockwave sneaky and
Jensen once again they are finding their
mark and darshan goes in with the Todd
even played out they got the damage
smoothies gonna get dropped this
contract falls down the itsy-bitsy
spider does not have walk for this world
and he is the last one left and running
teams and they're gonna end the win
streak here of cloud nine no more doc
what what's the whole backstory give me
from start to finish
dar doc joining the team day by day how
everything went all the way up to this
week we've got about 30 minutes this is
the support and each other might focus
for the kill at that point he knows it's
gonna go down one last hit concussive
blow and they take down double if
another one for guard on the Saturday
also here by the way alright stop watch
though we're gonna win Jim on a flash a
photo flash nice nice guys it'll flash
here we go 3 3 2 y by the way we get
this guy gets ok you think so yeah
putting video ok so flash yeah is that
for sure I can get I can get it here's
no flash
there can be Jay for soon soon yeah
second second
so echo fox is the fourth team that you
played with in the NA LCS what makes
this team different from the rest
and we're hella good now comes the real
defense for echo fox can they hold an
inhibitor turret
they're gonna try and make the play be
getting learned off backing there's a
buddy get him at home sir Mike go
straight to the background Adrian's
looking to run interference on the front
of it a massive him away from balsa
glades up baby we give her a little bit
go down it's so low remember he's not
here tonight right he literally just hit
level 6 Sox gonna try to take a Grove
yes top 5 star nachos are slam into the
wall to see see is too much the first
blood Oh - whoo wham bam they take them
down to that top lane oh my god Colonel
bull junglers looking to do what they do
best start us in for a gank body slam
flash room Baga for he could've done
anything at first blood comes through to
Phoenix absolute perfection out of Dar
doc stunts in the darkness just stack up
those heels again oh here comes Elise
though this my friend flash Oh flash
bird the cocoon predicted and that's a
dead yellow star don't lift can't do
anything about it
the dart Hawk hype what a cocoon right
there they wrap around mid caused it all
that cute landed early flap your own but
here comes the rest of the squad
svenskeren misses the cocoon he can then
just stay right next to him which is
huge for the skillshots
Roxanne Oh found dart off peekaboo the
rotation from period maybe on tied our
doc - his back was it just enough HP to
save him
Phoenix with the reaction is welcome
keep surprise her proxy he thought who's
gonna make a big play let's watch this
again
so garlic has both drops of his shotgun
in the dodge chases it gets to attack
saying because of this - gets and here's
the thing as he flashed over the wall it
allowed him to time to reload Matt
looking for a tornado off on the wall
bodyslam does hit moon bodyslam flash in
plenty of damage exhaustion Alltech he
burns the e actually learns relentless
pursuit to run away relentlessly Wow
another series one oblique with dart off
the three-man body slammed back-to-back
incredible stuff I don't necessarily
think anybody's better than me I don't
think I'm necessarily better than
everyone helping to get some first blood
for echo fox doc berry we get right back
in all tech went down first last fight
they were still to come out on top to
focus back hit and impact last story to
click on the hill Bob also has already
fallen but impact goes down
Smitty as well the retribution pills for
Alltech Jackson's waiting here if this
goes bad for golden Guardian through the
topside this is gonna spill out of
control and Jax is going to be a big
surprise he's gonna land the stunt at
the ball up there yes it is Laurel it
was down contracts running for his life
but he slowed down he was going through
one more hell calendar and this is a
disaster in the top played all three
kills up there already
darn I just read them like a book though
ten knock I'm gonna find just the woman
here comes chronic it as well to a three
versus two gonna spit narrow right back
out but pulling right back in now cats
and this is the to to get away the nice
pull back as Oh near the Taurus and he
comes in first blood comes through no
way out let's look back mom got involved
down the double pilfer all back and
that's not who you want to see when you
turn the corner they always are doc the
new player enters the fight and now it's
going to be a kill going on to Olay they
did not expect so many behind Adrian and
here comes Phoenix over the wall with
the blast cone gonna start slowing them
down gonna start locking them down
thinks the veins and has dar doc picks
up another kill for himself it's time to
make building your champions easier
introducing the score eSports new builds
calculator which allows you to plug in
items and runes to figure out which
builds give you the best stats the new
builds page also gathers information on
what the top players and your favorite
pros are building so you'll be able to
try them out yourself take control of
your champion and try out the new
feature on the score eSports build
website by clicking on the link in the
description below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button